hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here back
with another quick video and today I'm
going to be taking a look at how to get
the best audio quality out of your
computer now it's actually a pretty
simple process not even really a process
it's just really easy to do I have a
recommendation for you that's going to
do the trick now I watch a lot of setup
tours on YouTube or a lot of videos with
people setups or just geeks altogether a
lot of them just forget about audio even
you know regular people forget about
audio but even tech savvy people forget
about the audio component of their setup
so as a general whole let me introduce
you guys to da C's digital to audio
converters as a general rule people buy
external digital audio converters
because the internal ones that are built
into our computers that feed directly to
the output headphone jack basically are
typically really really bad audio files
just like pretty much any other files on
your computer or tablet or phone or a
laptop or desktop start off as binary
zeros and ones zeros and ones and they
need to be converted to an analogue
signal that will actually vibrate and
make you hear the sound that gets to
your ears so even if you have the
greatest speakers in the world the best
audio setup in the world if it's going
straight through the headphone jack
you're using the computer's internal DAC
and ultimately that's going to be pretty
bad and ends up being what we call a
bottleneck in your audio setup so you
can get the best sound out of those
digital files those zeros and ones with
a boss external audio converter and
usually that's going to go by a USB and
actually getting pretty inexpensive too
as of recently they've come down a lot
in price and I have a link in the
description so you can check some of
these out but they're getting really
down the audio engine d1 is a great
example it has a slim form factor a
really solid build and provides power to
your headphones as well through its
built-in amplifier so we're getting a
lot for your money and I feel like this
is more of a public service announcement
than anything but I just wanted to let
you guys know that if you are really
contemplating getting a really high-end
set up you can't forget about audio and
a digital audio converter is definitely
something you want to invest in in order
to make sure you get the best out of the
best of your audio so when I just
switched from the built-in audio jack in
my laptop to the audio engine d1 going
through the 80 hm 50s it sounded
actually a pretty solid difference I was
having fun turning it on and off
listening to the difference in sound and
you got a little punch
your deeper crisper base you got a
little bit wider soundstage and more of
a stereo sound effect it was really cool
and it definitely makes a big difference
so to get the best possible listening
experience the best possible sound out
of your music you want the highest
quality audio files possible those zeros
and ones and the highest quality digital
to audio converter possible which is
almost never the one that's built into
your computer so there they go and a
great pair of headphones usually helps
too thanks for watching give a thumbs up
on this video if you enjoyed it and I'll
talk to you later peace
you